windows 11 has already leaked all over
the internet
and so far based on what i'm seeing in
this new update
apple's upcoming m1x max and future even
more powerful max
are going to be completely free to reign
as the kings of the computer market now
before i get into explaining
exactly what i mean by using a brand new
wwdc 2021 developer video
that explains the insane advantages of
apple's chip technology
i want to quickly show you guys the
disappointment that
is windows 11. as you can see windows 11
has a new design
with a bunch of new icons that look
modern a new taskbar with centered apps
rounded corners on all the apps and a
new dark mode
which definitely looks nice and i've
gotta admit the new wallpapers look
absolutely amazing as well as a new
start menu
that's much improved compared to the old
one but look what happens when we dig
a little bit deeper all of the settings
and apps look essentially identical
to how they looked in windows 10 and
looking at the file explorer
it's literally a copy except with new
icons
so what's worrying people is the
possibility that windows 11
is just a reskin where they freshened up
the look of the ui and the icons and
called it good
like for example tom warren showed that
all of the old windows stuff
is still there within windows 11 like
the same command prompt
task manager and a basically identical
control panel
even more crazy the computer management
program
is still using decade old icons from
windows xp
so dylan an apple developer on twitter
decided to install windows 11
and check it out for himself and what he
ultimately confirmed
was that the code base is essentially
identical
to the one from windows 10 even
containing
this dialog box that hasn't been updated
in about 30 years
which is unbelievable this is a massive
problem because we all know that the
current version of windows
supports so much outdated hardware and
software
that the extra overhead actually slows
down the performance of modern computers
and since windows 11 uses the same old
code base
this is horrible news for windows laptop
makers since there won't be any major
speed improvements
to give them a much needed boost to
compete with apple's new m1 max
that are extremely well optimized for
example
dp review recently put the m1 imac
priced at 1900
against a much more expensive 2900 900
razer blade 15 advanced with an 8 core
i7 cpu an insane rtx 3080 gpu
with 16 gigs of vram and 32 gigs of
system ram
which is two times more than the m1 imac
has
and if you compare the graphics
performance the rtx 3080 is around five
to six times faster
than the m1 macbook pro's eight core gpu
so based on that massive difference
you'd expect the razer to easily wipe
the floor with the
m1 in terms of something very graphics
dependent
like video editing especially since it
has
double the system ram and not only that
but they tested premiere pro
which is actually running on the m1 mac
using a brand new
apple silicon beta version compared to a
fully optimized
native version on the razer blade but
shockingly the m1 mac
is somehow able to outperform the razer
in
every single task from exporting an
h.264
h.265 a master file and even processing
warp stabilization
which makes no sense at all if you
consider the difference in graphics
performance
and then watch what happens when we
introduce the completely optimized final
cut pro into the mix
the m1 mac is able to finish all of the
tests
in almost half the time absolutely
destroying the razer blade
this is insane because you're comparing
a 1900
m1i mac to a 2 900 razer blade 15 laptop
and what makes it even better is the
fact that the m1 imac performs
identically
to the m1 macbook pro which you can get
for even less either 1500 or 1700
depending on the storage these results
don't really make sense at
all especially for the premiere pro
tests which are obviously
favoring the windows laptop so the main
question that we have to answer is
how in the world is apple pulling this
off
well the answer is apple's absolute
obsession with
optimization which they've revealed in
this brand new wwc
2021 developer video explaining how to
optimize
video editing apps for apple silicon
chips like the m1 but before i get into
the incredible revelation shown in that
video
i want to go over some very important
details about apple silicon
from last year's wwc developer videos
first off a lot of people have the false
belief that the a core gpu
doesn't have any dedicated ram like the
vram
and instead relies on sharing the
limited system memory with the cpu
now yes it does share the ram but it
also has
its own dedicated tile memory for
rendering which actually works
incredibly well
here's an example of an unoptimized
workflow
which requires the data to be copied
back and forth
multiple times from the system memory to
the tile memory to finish rendering and
processing
and this is an example of the workflow
optimized for apple silicon
as you can see the tile memory is able
to handle this entire process by itself
which greatly saves time and uses much
less of the system's total ram
and let me remind you this is only
possible because of apple's unified
memory
architecture traditional x86 processors
and gpus
are forced into copying the data back
and forth
in order to finish the process so here's
a practical example to help you better
understand
how the unified memory works imagine
that there are two
artists one named cpu and one named
gpu both painting on a single canvas
that's essentially a task or process
that needs to be rendered or encoded
on a traditional x86 computer like the
razer blade 15
the artists are sitting on opposite ends
of a
table which let's say is called the ram
the cpu does a bit of painting
then sets it down onto the table
essentially copying the data to the ram
where the gpu picks it up and does its
own part of the painting process
before setting it back down onto the
table for the cpu to pick up
and finish the painting but with apple
silicon because of the unified memory
architecture
the cpu and gpu are essentially able to
sit
side by side both being able to paint
the canvas
at the same exact time or essentially
working on the task
without having to make multiple copies
to the ram
which greatly reduces the latency and
the ram usage
now getting back to apple's awesome tile
memory here's an
unoptimized programmable blending task
and here it is
with apple's tile memory in action
saving system ram usage
and here's yet another example that
usually requires multi-pass rendering
tile memory enables it to finish with
just a single pass
greatly reducing latency saving ram and
improving performance and if you're
wondering how all of this is possible
apple's gpu cores in the m1 have
multiple caches
like two dedicated l1 the tile memory
and last level cache so we can
essentially turn
an x86 based timeline like this with
multiple copies to the ram
to this just one at the end and now you
can begin to understand
how the m1i mac was able to outperform a
much more powerful computer
in real world tasks basically all due to
excellent optimization but wait it gets
even better with this brand new
developer video that's fully focused on
video rendering
first up apple reminds us that
everything from the neural engine
the cpu the gpu and the media encoders
can
access the unified system memory
simultaneously
without having to copy data back and
forth like in the example of
blitz which are essentially copies of
data that are required
on discrete gpus like the rtx 3080
because the system ram and vram are
separate
and blitz are usually required twice
from the cpu to the vram and then back
as you can see in this example
and now here's an example of an
optimized workflow on apple's m1 chip
no blitz at all allowing it to quickly
move on to the next frame
which is only possible due to that
unified memory architecture
next up we have this example which
basically shows that on traditional
chips
every compute dispatch requires the ram
to sync the data
globally before moving on to the next
compute task
putting a much heavier load on the ram
but with apple gpus like the m1
the tile memory itself can sync the data
and move on to the next compute task
without touching the ram at all until
it's ready for encoding
which greatly reduces ram usage and
latency on top of that
apple's gpus support memoryless
attachments
where a resource only exists in the tile
memory
for the lifetime of the encoder saving a
bunch of ram
and now getting into video editing tasks
specifically
which commonly include things like
unpacking the image channels
color space conversion applying luts
color correction
effects and packing the channel for
output or exporting
this can usually be very ram intensive
because each step needs to be copied to
and from the ram like in this example
which requires
2.16 gigabytes of memory traffic
to process a single 4k frame through
that complicated timeline
but with an apple gpu style memory it's
able to handle many of those tasks
without having to access the system ram
at all which ends up
reducing the memory bandwidth by a
massive 62
per frame and then on top of that
reducing it by 270 extra megabytes
thanks to only requiring one device
buffer as well as reducing cash
thrashing all of this ends up greatly
improving the performance of timeline
video playback while using less ram
and that's why in one of our recent
comparison videos
the m1 macbook air played at a perfect
24 fps
with decent overhead compared to the new
galaxy book pro
which played back at only around 12 fps
despite being not that much slower in
terms of raw graphics performance
and then finally finishing off with
encoding or exporting files
apple's unified memory architecture
allows both the video encoders
and the gpu to access the same data
files on the ram
without having to copy it back and forth
like traditional chips have to do
greatly reducing latency reducing ram
usage and
improving performance and that is how
the m1 imac with only 16 gigs of memory
was able to outperform the much more
expensive razer
blade that has double the ram a whopping
16 gigs of dedicated vram
and a much more powerful gpu but it
doesn't stop there
we tested the razer blade studio with a
quadro gpu that's very similar to the
rtx 3080
and the performance dropped by around 50
percent
when unplugged in order to save battery
life
which is something that doesn't happen
on m1 macbooks
because they're so efficient in fact
when we compared the 13-inch m1 macbook
pro to the 16-inch intel-based macbook
pro
the battery life on the m1 was at 66
percent
after three and a half hours of heavy
performance testing
while the 16-inch was almost completely
drained
which is absolutely insane and that's
all because with the new m1 max
apple is now the only company in the
world that controls the software
the chip and the actual computer all at
the same
time allowing them to reach never before
seen levels of optimization
that are literally impossible for their
competitors to reach
and what's disappointing about windows
11 is that the code base is essentially
the same
so all of those inefficiencies that stem
from having to support
a wide variety of outdated hardware are
all
still there needlessly slowing down
every single computer
that will run windows 11 for years into
the future and meanwhile
apple is continuing to push the envelope
in terms of software optimizations
to perfectly match their apple silicon
hardware
like for example eliminating the need to
copy data to the ram
while rendering ray tracing by doing
everything within the tile memory
and here's another example from the
developer video titled
optimize high-end games for apple gpus
with apple's unified memory architecture
you no longer need to use a blitz
encoder to copy game rendering data
to a private buffer since both the cpu
and gpu
can work on it at the same time
improving performance
so due to optimizations like this
apple's very first
and weakest apple silicon m1 chip is
already outperforming
much more powerful laptops in real world
tasks
and that is why even long time windows
users are finally switching to m1 max
because of the incredible performance
efficiency
and bang for the buck that's ironically
better
than recent premium windows laptops so
here's an interesting thought
if these m1 macs are performing this
well
imagine what's going to happen when
apple's much more powerful m1x macs are
released
it'll literally be a computing
revolution
with everyone including windows laptop
makers
getting their minds blown by the value
and performance
of the upcoming m1x max so hopefully you
guys enjoyed this video and if you did
go ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe
for more videos like this one definitely
check out one of those two videos right
there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one